hi i'm dean and i'll be presenting on
quantum distributed algorithms for
detection of clicks
okay so let's start with a two-minute
overview about what it is that we do
we tackle sub-graphic distance problems
in such problems we have some large
input graph we're given a small subgraph
and we're asked to do one or three
things with it
the first is to try to detect it does
the sub graph exist anywhere in the
input graph
the slightly more complicated version is
the count how many instances of the
subgraph exists in the input graph
and the final most complicated version
of these problems is listing we want to
give an actual list of all the instances
of the subgraph and antigraph
in a distributed world each of these
problems also has its own definition for
example for listing
every single computational unit in the
cluster has to output some list of the
instances of the subgraph that it sees
such that the union across all the
computation units is exactly the list of
all the subgraphs in the infograph
what we do here today
we show how to take an algorithm for
listing all clicks of a certain size
size p for any value p
in
distributed non-quantum setting and
convert it into an algorithm for
detecting clicks of larger size in the
quantum distributed setting and we do
this through a framework that we call
nested growth research
this is the first time in the
distributed
quantum computation
that grover searches were nested inside
one another all previous works only use
a single grover search where the
checking algorithm is classical not
quantum
second the way that we frame that we
show the framework allows allows to be
used without any knowledge of quantum
required that is any distributed
researcher can take our framework and
simply apply it as one more additional
tool
some examples for the results that we
show we take an algorithm for listing
all triangles that is clicks of size
three and end to the one over three
rounds in the non-quantum setting and we
show how to transform this algorithm
into one which detects clicks of size
four in the same round complexity
in general the main result that we get
is as follows the blue line shows how
long it takes to list a certain a
certain size click in the non-quantum
setting
and the red line shows how long it takes
our algorithms to detect those same
types of clicks
which for example for clicks of size
three for triangles listing requires n
to the one over three rounds in the
non-quantum setting and detection in the
quantum setting takes n to the one over
five using your results same goes ahead
for all the rest of the clicks of all
sizes we show faster results for any
size click
surprisingly also
this difference is separation in the
quantum setting because the lower bound
for listing actually holds and is the
same as the blue line also in the
quantum setting that is we show in the
quantum quantum student setting the
detection of clicks can happen faster
than listing such a separation is
currently unknown in the non-quantum
setting
okay
so before we delve into the quantum
stuff we back up a little and we see
what does subgraphic distance look like
in the distributed setting in the
non-quantum setting
so we deal with a model called congest
in the congest model we proceed in
synchronous rounds and every single
round two neighboring nodes can send a
log and bin message to one another when
we take this to the quantum setting the
only difference is that these bits can
be qubits
the computational measure in this model
is that we measure the number of rounds
it takes for an algorithm to halt the
local computation is considered for free
a slight modification of the congest
models look at just a click
in this model it's exactly like the
congest however
every two nodes can now communicate
every single round regardless of whether
or not they're neighbors so basically
here we split the graph into two cases
we have the input graph which is the
input that the nodes get and we're asked
to solve problems over the input graph
but the nodes communicate using the
overlay graph where every single node
can communicate with every other node
every single round
okay
so the the problem listing clicks was
first tackled in the congested click
setting where almost a decade ago was
shown how to list clicks of all sizes
it turned out this result was optimal
and matching lower bounds were shown
later on was shown that it's possible to
count triangles faster than to list them
however it was also shown
that it's
it's difficult to show any lower bounds
for this problem
practically any lower bound because
otherwise it would imply lower bounds
and circuit complexity
later results went ahead and also showed
algorithms which are sparsity aware and
they are tight that means that even if
the graph itself is sparse the infograph
it's possible to
to
list all clicks faster in those types of
graphs
leaving the congested click aside and
the problem almost solved there
completely
researchers turned their attention to
congest what happens in the congest
model which is way more restricted than
congested click
in this setting it took a line of really
beautiful works to get to an optimal
result which shows that listing all
triangles and congest takes n to the one
over three rounds and this is the same
round complexity as congested click
which is very surprising it's one of the
only problems currently known
whose complexity and congest and
congested click is identical
as for just detecting triangles
currently the best algorithm is still
the listing algorithm and takes n to the
one over three rounds it's an open
question whether this can be improved
but the only thing that we know in terms
of lower bounds is that we need more
than one round in order to solve this
problem and recently it was shown that
showing any polynomial lower bound is
difficult as it would imply bound in
circuit complexity
and this this area here that is still
untouched is a very big open question in
the distributed subgraph existence
problems
additional results for triangles include
as well local listing which is a variant
on listing and deterministic versions
since all the algorithms we just saw
almost all the others we just saw were
randomized
instilling congest now the big question
becomes what happens with clicks of
larger sizes what if we leave triangles
aside and get into clicks of size 4 5 6
and so forth
well a lower bound still holds and this
was known for a long time
recently algorithms were shown that were
sublinear in detect and listing all
clicks of all sizes until an algorithm
was shown that is optimal and lists all
clicks
optimally in the congest model and it
turns out this the same ramp complexity
as required in the congested click model
further it's also known that for clicks
of size 4
the time required to list or detect
clicks of size 4 in congest is exactly
the same and sits at square root of n
number of rounds
in the quantum distributed setting
some algorithms were
given however it began already in 2014
where it was shown that for many
problems it's not possible to speed up
using quantum computation
recently it was shown that it's possible
to compute the exact diameter faster and
even quadratically faster if the
diameter is small and it was also shown
that detecting triangles
in the quantum congestion model can be
done faster than in the non-quantum
contrast model in the co in the regular
congest model
as for the congested click there is only
one result currently known which is that
exact ap is speaking can be computed
faster than what's known classically
okay
so let's delve into what we do
we'll start with a warm up we'll take an
algorithm for listing clicks of size p
and extend it using just grover search
to an algorithm for detecting clicks of
size p plus one
okay and we'll do this in the congested
click recall that in the congested click
every two every two nodes can
communicate every single round log n
bits to one another and the quantum can
just click it's login qubits okay grow
for search basically works like this
say that we have a binary array and we
know that at least one of the entries is
one
it's possible in n and square root of n
number of queries to find such an entry
or to say that no entry exists and that
is that the entire array is zeros in a
more general form we have some function
f which gets input from some domain
capital x
and gives us an and we we desire to find
some x star such that f gives it one
if such an x star exists then it's
possible to do so in
square root of the domain size
recently it was shown how to use grover
searches in the distributed setting and
basically the way that it's done in the
distribute setting is as follows the
function f becomes a distributed
algorithm that means that we have some
leader node which coordinates the search
and locally performs the search and
whenever we have some value x which we
want to query the function f with
the leader node gets this value x
and then runs some algorithm using the
entire network to compute the value f of
x and after some c number of rounds the
leader node should have f of x stored in
it this is an entirely distributed
algorithm which computes this f of x
and then the leader can using that using
such a privilege using such a tool the
leader node can run the rover search
locally to find such an x star and the
number of rounds that it takes is the
number of rounds it takes for a query of
one
result which is c rounds times square
root of the size of the domain this is
distributed over search an adaptation of
the well-known grover search to the
distributed setting
okay
so how does it work in our setting
we start with an algorithm for listing
clicks of size p for some value p for
example four so we list all clicks of
size 4 and that means that every single
node in the graph outputs some list and
the union of all these lists is exactly
all the clicks of size 4. for example
perhaps this purple node will output
this orange click it doesn't have to be
that the node outputting the cluster the
click is one of the nodes itself in the
in the click itself
okay how can we check given that we did
this how can we check
if there's a click of size five
well how can we check if a certain node
for example this node participates in a
click of larger size
if we tell all its neighboring nodes to
broadcast that they neighbor this green
node
then every single node in the graph
which we'll know
of of a k4 that can be extended to a k5
using the green node we'll be able to to
see this for example take this pink node
here that already knows this cluster
this click of size 4 surrounding the
green node once these nodes broadcast
that they neighbor the green node the
pink node will be able to detect that
such a click of size five exists
okay
so this basically is an algorithm for
detecting if a single vertex can extend
a given click of size p to a click of
size p plus one and it takes us of one
round in the click to check this for one
vertex
so that means that if we check all the
vertices using a grover search within a
square root n number of rounds we can
check if any vertex can extend some
click of size p that's already known to
a click of size p plus one
this gives us that we can perform k p
plus one detection and square root of n
number of rounds plus the round
complexity that it takes for listing
clicks in the classical setting
okay
now let's try to
bring it up one more notch what if we
nest the grover searches and instead of
extending by one weeks then the clicks
buy some t for some value t
okay so here's the algorithm this is
where we stopped previously
the classical step was to list all the
clicks of size p
then we have some classical checking
algorithm to detect if a click
if we should extend the click by one
using some node and we and we ran this
using a grover search
what if we change the quantum algorithm
itself the the checking algorithm itself
and make it quantum instead of classical
intuitively what we get is investing the
growth researches we have some setup
cost which is some qua some classical
algorithm that we run and then we
perform some grover search
and the checking function itself is also
a grover search which nests other grover
searches
for example let's see how we extend by
two
when we try to extend by two we have
already listed all clicks of size p
and we want to check if there's a pair
of nodes we can which can extend some
known click of size p to click the size
people's two
the problem with so the intuitive option
is to just search over all pairs and for
each one to broadcast their neighbors
and see if it can extend a click to a
larger size
the problem with this is that the search
space is at least n squared and so no
matter how long it takes us to check a
single pair we'll take at least
end rounds
to overcome this we do the following we
take the search space and we partition
it into parts such that we we have
square root of n parts called a 1 to a
squared of n
and we search over these batches so i
assume that the cost of searching over
one batch is c to see if the if the if
this batch has some pair which extends
the k p to k p plus two
if we search over all batches and
quantumly it'll take n to the one over
four rounds times c since they're n to
the one over two batches
okay so what's this value c how long
does it take to check if the single
batch extends has a pair which extends
the kp to k plus 2.
what we do here is we do the following
we start by broadcasting all the
neighbors of ai
and this takes square root of number of
rounds since that's the size of ai
what we do then
we search now over
the nodes v to see if there is some node
in v
which given some node in ai extends both
of these together extends sum k p to k p
plus two this is done exactly like we
did the extension to k
to p plus one simply by having the nodes
and v broadcast their degrees throughout
the quantum search and this takes n to
the one over two rounds because we have
n nodes and checking for a single node
simply amounts to broadcasting its
neighbors and that's all and that takes
over one round as we saw a second ago
what this gives us is that checking if a
certain batch has a pair that extends
from kp to kb plus 2 takes square root
of a number of rounds
so if we plug this value in instead of c
we get that the round complexity for
checking
if there's if there are two nodes which
can extend the kp to kb plus 2 takes n
to the 3 over 4 rounds
but wait why did this work why
intuitively did we manage to go below
end rounds for extending by two nodes
the reason being that when we broadcast
the neighbors of ai
classically and then we perform the
quantum search throughout the quantum
search this classical information is
being reused
that is we broadcast this information
once classically but without the quantum
searches every single node can still use
this classical information because they
possess it
okay
so in general what we get here we can
extend this up to some any value team
and what we get is that if we
apply the known quantum and the known
classical algorithm for listing clicks
of size p
and add add to it our addition which
extends by team rounds we get the
following runtime for detecting clicks
of of any size
and so for example if we want to detect
clicks of size 5 we can run a k4 listing
algorithm and then extend by 1. if we
want to detect clicks of size 36 for
example it's optimal to run an algorithm
for listing clicks of size 32 and then
extend by
4. okay
so
we managed to show an algorithm which
allowed us to extend clicks however it
turns out that it doesn't improve the
run time for clicks of size 3 and clicks
or size 4.
the reason being that even for just our
plus one extension we need to pay square
root of n number of rounds
however
listing clicks of size three and of size
four takes n to the one over three n to
the one over two rounds respectively
already so our extension doesn't help
for these cases
and so it turns out that in order to
solve this problem what we need to do
so far we used a black box listening
algorithm we just used an existing
algorithm somewhere in the congested
click and we didn't use any of the
properties specifically to a certain
algorithm
we need to open up this box we need to
now tailor this listening algorithm to
be able to work with the quantum
algorithms that we show
and so let's start with an example of
how we take k2 listing and show k3
detection out of it well k2 listing is
basically just a redistribution of the
edges in the graph because k2 is just an
edge
okay
so we start by taking the the set of
nodes in the graph v and just
arbitrarily partitioning it and to enter
the one over five parts where each part
is roughly the same size
we create another partition the green
partition into n to the two over five
parts it's the same partition we just
copied it here twice on the slide two
green partitions which are the same and
the blue partition
now what we do is
for every single node u in the graph
we give it a triplet of parts that is
two parts in the green partition and a
blue part
it turns out that there are exactly n
ways to choose three parts in such in
such a manner and so every single node
on the graph can choose one triplet one
specific unique triplet of parts
then what node you will do it'll
classically learn all the edges between
its green parts and
since they're n to the six over five
edges between these two parts it's
possible to do so and enter the one over
five rounds classically it's possible to
show how this can be
done now we do
the node u will take its part in the
blue in the blue partition and break it
up and to enter the two over five
subparts which also have n to the two
over five nodes each
and notice now the number of edges
between every single one of the subparts
and the green parts is at most and edges
and so it's possible to show in the just
a click that node u can learn these n
edges
in one round
and so basically what node u now has is
the ability to check if any of these
subparts can
can give a triangle in o of one rounds
and
node you can run a quantum search over
all its subparts and solve this and
detect if there exists a triangle using
what with a node in every single one of
its parts it entered the one over five
rounds
all nodes in the graph do this in
parallel for their triplets and so what
we get that an end to the one over five
rounds all the nodes on the graph can
check if there's just a triangle in the
graph
in general we can extend this to any np
and not just k3 detection
based off by taking the algorithm the
listing algorithm from 2012 and
augmenting it directly with our quantum
quantum
quantum searches
and we can also extend it to just to
plus t and not just plus one that is we
can add any number of nodes that we want
to and what we end up getting is the
following formula for kp detection where
if we want to detect clicks of a certain
size we should admit we should minimize
on
what size click queue we want to list
and then extend that by t more to get to
p
okay so far we just talked about the
quantum congested click how about
quantum congest what happens there in
the much weaker model
so in the in the congest model recall
that every two nodes can send a message
to one another whereby the congested
click every two notes send a message to
one another and they can just every note
every neighboring notes can send a
message to one another
this is what we did a second ago
for detecting triangles and the quantum
congested click
in order to turn this into a congest and
quantum congest algorithm we need to do
two things the first is we need to
randomize these partitions they can't be
arbitrary and this is to help out with
load balancing problems which occur in
congest and not congested click
and the second we have to attach this to
a framework which was shown for listing
triangles
in the congest setting and we combine
the framework with what we showed here
in order to get the algorithm incongest
finally we also show how to extend
clicks
of any given size listing to detection
of plus one of that
and and the way we did this in the
congested click setting
was that we searched over all the nodes
and for every single node we broadcast
in of one rounds it's neighbors however
in the congest setting this can be very
very challenging to do
and so what we have what we end up
having to do we take the framework which
was recently shown for listing clicks of
any size in the congest setting and we
augment that what this framework gives
us is that one we only have to consider
nodes with very high degree
where the degrees at least the average
degree in the in the congest model and
it's also at least enter the two over
three round
nodes
and we're also given that messages can
be sent very quickly in this setting
basically meaning that even though we're
in congest
any two nodes can communicate messages
to one another as long as no note sends
more than o if it's the green number of
messages per round
and so given these constraints that the
the framework allows us to assume
instead of just working in the normal
congest model
we now bucket the nodes in the graph
according to the degrees and we go over
each of the log n buckets
in each bucket we search over the nodes
in that bucket to see if one of them can
extend an unknown k click of size p to p
plus one
working out the math shows that it's
possible to search over each bucket and
enter the two over three rounds since we
have login buckets it takes otilda which
is
uh login times times enter the two for
three rounds in order to search if
there's any node in the graph which
extends the kp to kb plus 1.
finally also in congest we show low
visual hardness of proving lower bounds
it was shown previously that for cycles
it's difficult to show lower bounds for
cycles either because it's impossible
using two player communication
complexity or because showing lower
bounds would imply lower bounds for
circuit complexity it was also shown
that for triangles it's really difficult
to show any prob any lower bound any
polynomial will be bound for detection
of triangles
we go ahead and we extend this and we
show that for clicks of any size it's
difficult to show lower bounds
higher than n to the three over five
polynomially higher than to the three
over five and we do this by combining
the lower bound
for triangles with the framework which
was recently shown and some additional
observations that we have
okay so to summarize everything that
we've been through we're starting the
quantum conjunct click and we show how
to extend click listing of size p to
click detection of size people's one by
searching over the nodes in the graph
if we wanted we later show how to extend
using nested grover searches by t and
not just by one
we also then open up the comp the the
listing algorithm itself and adapt it to
use to be able to use specifically with
our quantum searches this also allows
listing detection triangles in k4 faster
also it shows a faster result for
general clicks
in quantum congest we go ahead and we
take our k3 detection algorithm from the
click
and we
add sparsity awareness to it by having
this randomization and some load
balancing techniques
and in order for clicks of larger sizes
we have to use the the frameworks which
were recently introduced
finally also in congest and in quantum
congest we show we show hardness of
showing lower bounds for detecting
clicks of any size
and this is based on combining the
recent hardness which was shown for
triangles where the framework was
recently shown and some of our
additional observations
thanks so much for listening this is it
for today